welcome everybody for the Thursday
evening a 7:30 class this game class
we're gonna be going over the current
games so we talked about current
tournaments
you know and I chose this one game to
show that we don't have any like big
tournaments coming up we don't have any
tournaments right now some big events
the big event that is gonna start in
about two weeks it's gonna be the
candidates tournament in Russia that's
gonna be the big event and then we're
gonna have a masters from us for no
Khurrana number two in the world he will
be playing there and hopefully he can
win it again to qualify to the match
World Championship matches so right now
there's no like huge tournament but I
found this game it's it's an annual
tournament in Russia in Moscow they had
the youth versus the experienced GM so
there's a youth is the all-russian youth
players like this game
with white is grandmaster lee sem ko
2650 and his opponent is a person
grandmaster who played for the World
Championship match Boris Gelfand
if you remember he played against Vishy
Anand in 2012 but came short came short
he lost and tiebreaks
but so that's the so it's se panko is
white his opponent is a very experienced
Grandmaster Boris Gelfand from Israel c4
c5 first of all what is the name of this
opening huh English perfect and when
black plays c5 oftentimes this is
referred to as a symmetrical English
okay so he goes here Knight f3 Knight f6
as you can see they're copying each
other moves Knight c3
96 so far we see a complete copying of
the moves okay
copying the moves here so now he goes
here
d4 down things are gonna get a little
bit different white the master the
sip-n-go goes for an aggressive line
yeah you can also play something like g3
here but that would be more a slow
buildup type of position okay so he was
here here takes c6 in our g3 the point
of g3 is to develop the bishop on g2 and
try to castle as soon as possible okay
the idea is to Kobe sheep g2 and Castle
Queen b6 play by Gelfand immediately
putting pressure on the night
Knight b3 well it's not so easy to
defend the night here because you cannot
use your Bishop to go to e3 because it's
going to take your pawn okay it's not so
easy and if you take you don't want to
do this because then it's gonna give a
big center okay sorry so 96 is just
gonna take that for the pawn so it goes
here Knight b3 Knight e5 plate putting
pressure on which pawn now the night
only five is attacking c4 pawn right
just attacking this pawn and you have to
do something about it so the movie for
was played opening up the diagonal for
the bishop to defend the c4 pawn okay
Bishop g4
now
what to do
what do you think white should do here
Bishop g2 that's a possibility but
Bishop g2 if you go who you will be
protecting this pawn here who will be
protecting that time nobody right so
that's going to be taken so that's why a
c5 Quincy 6 plate if you take this I
think this is just just pace yeah it's
this new new trespass is just doing not
familiar with it yet it's just there's
something different I can do show
variations that is okay so that Queen c6
okay
if he takes a fix this because it's not
letting me show auditions okay it's just
all right sir
so if you take if you take there is a
you know if you go 94 here's Bishop f2
check okay and this is not so good
because check and take tonight it takes
i take takes
I think you're just you know white who
played this position because is extra to
bishops and dark squares are weak it's
more like you play for the initiative
you know Castle we should be three f45
something like that this no no you're
too strong bishops you have two strong
bishops so again for North Quincy six
now he is threatening to take the pawn
on e4 Queen takes e4 for example okay so
white goes Bishop g2 developing the
bishop are hoping to castle soon but
Queenie six plate when a sixth-grade and
now the White King cannot castle
now the white king cannot cancel and
we're stuck now because the queen is
saying this and you cannot pass your
King through that line okay
and also there is a threat of 93 check
out there as well that we have to deal
with okay
what to do here what to do here let's
pass a little bit and try to see yes
wage
well well let's first first things first
this night is pinned
first things first night is pinned you
can't move it hey do something different
hey Bishop back are we gonna make a draw
here no we're not gonna come on we're
not gonna make a draw here yeah we can
do this but that's just repetition right
there will be a repetition I don't think
we want to draw having the white pieces
is an advantage remember advantage you
start again with you know you dictate
you play the first move so I don't think
this guy's gonna do that what else what
else you can think of here
well actually well I'll tell you this
so c5 here he paid here Bishop g2 and
now very important move here needed
active move needed here okay you know
forget about this 93 check thread you
know it's okay just try to do something
different let him do that check if you
really wants to
correct
yes it is it is undefended well what can
you do
one on the Left website
sorry what's the move here yeah this one
here ah pawn yes yeah but check
structure is roomed right check and
that's a lot of problems here and I'm
afraid there are serious problems you
know something special you need
lots of chat and also to threaten me
yeah that might be an okay idea but the
correct idea is Queen D for guys queen D
for activating your pieces putting
pressure putting pressure look
centralizing your queen okay
centralized now it plays d6 trying to
complicate the matters because if you go
here actually just go skin d2 there's
some problems with this Bishop you know
if you take I take I mean it's just a
lot of development already been played
and black is still not developed this
could be a very very big problem here
okay
so that's why I played the move d6 so
you have to take what else to do nothing
and now he goes knight c6 attacking the
Queen he probably did not like this
because there are ideas like this
there's 93 threat here but even after
castle it feels like white is better you
know there's a lot more potential for
him Knights are coming in this Bishop is
undeveloped maybe some potential at
forty five even out there so this is a
really really nice position for white
so he goes ninety six is trying to
attack the Queen so we what to do
now we have to move the Queen but where
well you got to move it somewhere well
you don't want to just drop the d-46
pond for no reason right so you want to
stay with it okay
all right goes here
yeah if you go up it's gonna be a
repetition but this player is a banquet
actually played him is very aggressive
young young younger master so he's not
going to be okay with the draw he's
gonna try to push for the push push for
the maximum he's gonna try to push for
the maximum
we can't castle Queen is still guarding
it
you're still cannot castle
well look that night on e5 is annoying
it's been sitting there for a while now
right you kind of sort of wanna whenever
the position like this too much tension
you want to resolve this you want to
kind of you know move this night from
here because I've been sitting there for
a long time
yep and if you get lucky you want to
play e5 and cement the position then
you're winning
so he goes check obviously this was
expected and you have only one move here
because everything else loses yeah
because you cannot go to e-file and
therefore because then he just takes
your Bishop with the check and you need
to resign sir to go here now
now he took Bishop takes nice so if you
take what the Queen you gonna run into
night check here take so you take with
this now it takes 1 c1
and now you have choice here you have
four different ways you can capture here
four different ways you can capture but
which one is the logical and the best
which one is the logical and the best
I'm sorry okay well we got to figure out
which one actually exactly well the
problem is you know you have a passed
pawn and we know that you want to have
your look behind the pospone right
if you leave your King on d1 you're not
going to be able to do that okay so the
choice is my method of simple
elimination we realized that which one
is the best and the best is King take c1
now obviously if I play e5 it's just
over I'll be just winning this so he
plays ePHI himself to try to open up his
light square bishop
yeah things get a little complicated but
if you didn't play that well if you had
castle for example that wasn't very bad
after this is just white is just gonna
win this game okay because of the
protected passport so ii v AP goes
Knight g4 girl phone goes 94 putting
pressure on e5
now he is attacking the pawn but you
have to continue your plan and our plan
was rook d1 right get the rookin he
castles
and 95 looks interesting but I think
there is a queen d5 from very strong so
that's I didn't want to play 9500 in the
castle first
and now I can win some material how
takes because otherwise I go d8 I go
further like did another Queen so he
takes who white put a look behind it
check
tract
animating
huh
yeah now what to do Kish
yeah because if you give block couple of
moves ninety-five Bishop e6 he's gonna
get out and then this might be a little
liability here you know this might be a
liability here so we don't we don't want
to do that
then do we have any questions from our
YouTube audience how to win material
it's okay it's okay
better better concrete concrete move you
have here your winning a material I
don't want to say which piece because
then it's easy perfect
have you smooth you know now you say
give me the pictures retakes if he goes
here once again check wonderful
background checkmate ok so he takes
Queen takes he goes Knight e3 hitting
the rock
now he's attacking my rook I mean at
this point it's pretty clear that white
is probably winning just the dirtiest
tricks you know you have to deal with so
one thing you want to do when you're
head you want to get the Queen's off the
board
okay that's that's a very important
thing to do 26 so it goes p6 now just
simply move the rock up to defend it
and taro kc8 wondering why I did not
take because there's a queen f1 check
here
well I guess you can't take but you can
now if the idea is just a booking
between take
so that's my place rook ac8 putting
pressure now on c3 pawn
and now very interesting but very
concrete play by Grandmaster se pemko
and see if you can see it
now which piece you think we can try to
activate here and preferably we can
activate by temples right temples are
very important in the game of chess you
make a move you put pressure temples
okay so what you do here
Misha page three attacking the rook so
it's clear he's gonna go check now where
do you go here you want to make sure you
avoid putting the King on awkward
squares okay and you got to think of in
the future you got to get a look into
the game to that look that is still
sitting on a1 but this game is just so
concrete there is no time to get to get
everything in it you know
be too
now attacking the rook and now he checks
thinking yes I got the Quinn but let's
do a little count at the end takes takes
takes strong passed pawn on d6 two minor
pieces rook sorry bishop the three minor
pieces for a queen and a pawn so I mean
essentially this is a just a winning
position despite losing the Queen you
gain a lot of materials so this is just
great for you yeah people will people
are not taking beat you people would be
other thing people would also give up
the c3 pawn because it's just they would
be like but you just don't have a
comfortable way of defending against
this
so that's why play bish page 3 takes
king between play check takes pawn takes
Queen a tree of course he's going to try
to make it as hard as possible for you
not to go back but now what do you do
pass pounds meant to be pushed goes here
and we have some piece that hasn't moved
yet and we are on a move 28 okay that's
something we shouldn't do too often okay
we shouldn't be doing this too often
huh
see one because you want to move the
King over to D file and start going to
c8 okay so it goes g6
now what to do with this King can you
have to be careful because if you make
one mistake then you know it can get out
of hand here a little bit
rook t5 no but again we played this move
to be able to get rook on c8 right so
that's that you should try to stay with
a plan okay King III to go to tonight is
f5 he's trying to disconnect the defense
so he can pick up the spawn so we're not
gonna let him do that we want to keep
the d7 pawn because that's a winning
winning pawn here it's gonna Quinn so
what to do here he wants to take na now
he created threat he wants to take it
III my gosh Quinn is 7 now he's pinning
and threaten to take this
now what can you do here that you don't
lose your d7 pawn because it's a very
very important part
okay
now he takes cheque
no simply we want to bring our bishop in
right you did bishop did the job so just
come back and now I just need to find
the finishing finishing touches session
three more three moves and he resigned
actually two moves but you should also
mention the third idea third move idea
once he plays King g7 now he wants to
take on d7 right so what can you do to
stop that
takes rook takes now do now it's tricky
you gotta keep protecting the D pawn and
then you have to get a knight on c6 or a
six so you got to kind of protect this
but at the same time you gotta get a
knight their roopd fight fantastic yes
and in there no more moves he resigned
because your plan is very simple now he
designed because of what
and now you have 96 ideas
now will you remove the Queen and
promote upon in the Queen I think it's a
very exciting fascinating game by young
Grandmaster se PEMCO to defeat such a
experienced player that Boris Gelfand so
the youth is taking over all right
everybody
do you have any questions about this
game so again if you want to find this
game it's the AC Penco against white
against girl fun you can just search
that and they just play this okay okay
we're gonna be doing some important in
game positions for you at the end okay
this one is
Bishop endgame white to play and win
bishop endgame we're trying to promote
this b-pawn into queen so we're very
close but it's not easy because if you
promote he is gonna sacrifice and it's
going to be a drop
can you work your bishop
yeah well you you thought that the only
thing you have so you're gonna go here
if he's not defending accurately please
like a regular mood then you're gonna
win easily because you're gonna bring
the bishop we're f - now you're gonna
get him out of the long diagonal which
is very important factor in the same
games now you like go away from this
diagonal so it goes here and now you can
just go here threatening to Quinn and if
it goes here this should be hole
deflection and you win the bishop or if
it takes your bishop you promote into a
queen and then you give a mate okay but
when you play Bishop h4 might have
crossed your mind this is the move that
you got to see because easily Bach is
gonna keep the king on a6 to prevent you
from getting the bishop out of - that
long diagonal you have to move his king
from a long diagonal to a short one okay
so remember from the this is the is this
diagonal is too long so you have to put
in a short one
okay
it goes here well you're not gonna go
anywhere else because anywhere else
you're gonna go Bishop be a [ __ ] pay
seven it says to go here and now you
have to do litter this next one is very
important because you can promote the
pawn is a draw you can move the King so
it's pretty clear what your next move is
but you have to find the right square
for that piece
everyone is just gonna go to g3 you're
not going to be able to just so yeah
this is not gonna do anything basically
so what to do here
huh close but there's another square you
have to use with your bishop right now
which is important yes
now King cannot move because you have
this bishop a selfish P so the only
thing left is I'm gonna move the bishop
now you see now his bishop is not on h2
now we go back right because we are
threatening to play now Bishop here and
here so to cover up the position okay
with Bishop d8 you should system so he
has to go here to prevent that now what
do you do
now if it goes here then you win because
of Bishop c7 so he's gonna go to c6 okay
he's going to go to c6
but now when he's on c6 you have
something here
now compared to the original position
there is a slight difference in original
position his bishop was on h2 which was
a better place piece but here it's not
and here you have an opportunity to do
something to win this game absolutely
absolutely
Bishop age 4 now you're attacking this
bishop if he takes you promote into a
queen it has to go here
do what Bishop f2 perfect now you cannot
prevent you because you're going to go
in there so if you go here
what so we go here he waits here he
waits
now you go here threaten to promote he
goes here and now
No
takes a lot of calculation yeah so you
have to understand yes I understand when
you reach this position every move is
critical
the surgeon so all you did that in the
beginning you did all this maneuvering
with the bishop to get the same position
with this Bishop on g3 and with the
bishop on GT then you win because you
have this Bishop h4 move comes in with
the temple okay so here here well this
just wins
yeah yeah yeah right here
I think you use Bishop c5 is very
important let's say you're doing the
same thing in this way right it's not
gonna work now here's Bishop is well
placed on d6
yeah
so that's why after this idea so this
graph for
check you you're controlling the d6
square so the bishop doesn't have the
square so he goes here now we go back to
the original position okay
yeah
no one here
so that's that's the idea Bishop c5
Bishop e7 now threatening to go here and
here so he has to go to b8 and show me
the finish here how do we finish it yes
how do we finish it
well somebody no not yet not yet check
first he has to go here and now
no no have to if I go to c6 then we go
back to for which idea
h4 you go you go Sears
and you go here threating Bishop b8
yeah but eventually you get to the
position it's yeah it is a little bit
dancing around but you are improving it
you're not just just going around in
circle you're improving it and getting
to the winning position okay
okay perfect excellent job everybody
thank you for attending this class we'll
be here next Thursday okay same time
[Music]